foreign
welcome to the academy Museum of Motion
Pictures the largest institution in the
United States devoted to the Arts
sciences and artists of movie making
the academy Museum of Motion Pictures
acknowledges the tongva people as the
traditional caretakers of the water and
land on which we program curate educate
convene and discuss we honor and respect
tongva ancestors and the tongva
community today which continue to
nurture this land and water through
traditional practice activism art and
education we acknowledge their continued
work to safeguard cultural resources
my name is Bernardo Rondo I am the
senior director of film programs here at
the Museum thank you for joining us in
our beautiful David Geffen Theater for
the international feature Film nominees
panel presented as part of our Oscar
week programming
before we begin the panel public
programming for 2023 Oscar week is made
possible by the Ruderman Family
Foundation which promotes authentic
representation in the entertainment
industry and full inclusion of people
with disabilities throughout all sectors
of society
allowing me to introduce our ASL
interpreters for this panel Richard Loya
and I'd like to ask Felix Villarreal and
Paola Morales to also join on stage
for your power yeah Paul's already here
now please help me in welcoming to the
stage senior vice president of member
relations Global Outreach and award and
awards Administration dilcia Barrera
[Applause]
hello on behalf of the international
feature film Administration team
including Jose Gallegos and Camille de
los Santos we would like to welcome you
today the international feature film
category is proof of the love and
admiration the academy has for Global
Cinema the interests in filmmakers and
their stories from around the world is
high and we're so happy to see this
reflected not only in the membership but
also in all aspects of this organization
this year we received 92 submissions
from selection committees representing
six continents for months members from
across the world participated in
watching discussing and voting to form
this category shortlist and then
participated in selecting this
categories nominees
we thank and acknowledge the hard work
of the international feature film
executive committee who helps oversee
the rules regulations and eligibility of
this category as well as the
international feature film voting
committee for their dedication to these
films these filmmakers and this award
tonight it is our honor to have with us
the international feature film category
executive committee co-chairs Susana
beer and rajendra Roy they're joining us
as hosts and moderators
Suzanne and Raj are wonderful Partners
they're great leaders and we're so
grateful that we get to work with them
year round so now please help me welcome
to the stage Susanna beer and rajendra
Roy
thank you
good afternoon
buenas noches
and
those are the languages of the films we
are honoring tonight including donkey
for those of you that don't speak there
at the end
this is a celebration of International
Film welcome
[Applause]
we will love tonight not only for the
International Film feature category
but for the community of filmmakers and
film lovers alike
as dilcia mentioned the nominated
International feature films were voted
on by hundreds of Academy members from
all over the globe this year they
collectively committed many hours of
their time to view the 92 films that
were submitted to represent their
respective countries many of these
dedicated members are here with us
tonight and we'd like to thank them for
their commitment passion and hard work
please give a round of applause to the
executive and voting committee members
of the international feature film
category and please stand if you're here
with us thank you so much
[Applause]
the international filmmakers who are
here with us tonight help remind us why
we fall in love with the movies
they introduced us to unique characters
and transported us to different
locations and themes
from the Battlefront of the first world
war to the trials of the Gentiles from
an acrimonious split of a grade school
friendship to the story of an abandoned
girl and finally the Journey of a donkey
let's take a look at the five film
nominated for best International feature
film
come on
so yeah
oh
this is
for me
okay
foreign
[Music]
what to do
okay
[Music]
foreign
the Todo
ches
okay
foreign
[Music]
all right
hey
guys
[Music]
push
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
yeah
Aaron Garlington
is
a friend in this quotation
okay
thank you
foreign
and now please welcome our five nominees
from Ireland Colin burred director of
the quiet girl
[Applause]
from Poland Jersey scalimowski director
of EO
[Applause]
from Belgium Lucas Dante director of
close
from Argentina Santiago Mitra director
of Argentina in 1985.
and from Germany Edward Berger director
of All Quiet on the Western Front
[Applause]
welcome gentlemen and I
am slightly anxious about just saying
gentlemen
um
but welcome gentlemen and
congratulations to you and to your
countries
you've been sharing your remarkable
films with audiences all over the world
and I'm sure you're a little bit tired
of speaking about your own movies
so now as part of our new tradition
we would love for each of you to speak a
little bit about each other's films
come
since you are representing Ireland at
the Oscars for the first time in this
category
perhaps you could start
[Applause]
perhaps you could start and share some
thoughts about EO
thank you um
I just watched you yesterday actually so
it's quite fresh in in my mind and um
I was I was blown away but I'm I mean
what what really struck me about it was
I mean I thought our film was going to
be the most non-verbal
I guess yeah donkey's always going to
beat you on that front
but um
what I loved about it was like you know
Jersey is obviously a legendary
filmmaker and you know as a long and
very distinguished career and yet you
watch EO and there's such a beautiful
curiosity to the filmmaking and an
energy to it and it uh a Vitality to it
that's really inspiring to me and
um
I I loved how
EO in a sense like the EO is the the
donkey at the center of the piece and um
EO in a sense is is almost like a mirror
um for us as the audience and a mirror
of of us
um
and all of our failings and
at times the the sort of the better
angels of our nature as well
um
but I just thought it was an astonishing
piece of work and there was such a such
an audacity to the like formally such an
audacity to to what Jersey had created
and
um yeah I would urge urge you all to
watch it
thank you Carl
Edward let's move to this side of the
line
um perhaps you could share some thoughts
on close
um yes
um Lucas I want to send you a little
love letter about your film
um I saw it a few months ago and I
thought it was the most beautiful film
in its confidence and its precision and
its silence and it's
observation and it's acting I mean I've
never seen any children
or young young men act as beautifully as
as the two boys that you found that you
can tell a wonderful story about where
you found them and then oh I can tell it
for you
um if you got tired of it and uh it has
a 10 your camera has a tenderness uh in
the way you watch your uh protagonists
in in the way you follow them without
being obtrusive just observant and just
letting them be in front of the camera
an amazing confidence and I think like
having watched all of your films is a
wonderful development in in and a
wonderful
language that you have developed that is
very you I think that no one else really
has and the story is so simple but yet
so archaic or biblical uh that it uh it
has a profound impact when you watch it
and you you as a viewer you uh move into
your what I love about it also you I
move into
um uh at a sense of time that is very
your film you know it's outside of
reality it's like I'm basically you take
me into another space and I live in that
space for two hours and I watch these
two boys and suddenly I come back and
I'm back in reality and I've been moved
to to another world for two hours
because of the way you you treat your
subjects and um
I remember one shot which is so I mean
that just your your visual I mean then
you've you know be it ice hockey or be
it uh be it the flower uh shop every
location every decision you make in
terms of your directorial decisions
they're so clearly uh driven by a story
that it's just wonderful to see and I
remember one shot for example that how
it translates to camera is when the two
boys cycle home
and silently you know or just I think
they maybe say a few words and you
already feel the rift between them and
then slowly you know the two paths take
them apart and one goes straight and the
other sort of takes off and so on one
shot you follow these two and you know
already okay
they are drifting apart they're taking
different paths in life and uh they make
these decisions and all your filmmaking
is driven by uh these type of decisions
where your locations your costumes your
production design your your dialogue
it's all is in service of you know
suddenly uh taking your Audience by the
hand and and uh taking
um leading making them Escape into a
different world and it's just wonderful
to see
thank you so much
share something about Argentina 1985.
well I guess I was chosen to
speak about Argentina
1985 because
in my country Poland
we had
quite similar experience of
um
living under the dictatorship
and
we suffer
not such big tragedies as the
as the thirty thousand
missing people but
numbers are not really
decisive in this case I think the
atmosphere of
life under the dictatorship is such
that
it twists its
Twisted the souls
of people
and making a huge damage to the you know
to this
the whole nation
so I watched the film with that
knowledge of what we went through
and I must say that
in the private conversation with the
director I I asked him couple of
questions which were
and I was very surprised with the with
the answers
he managed to shoot this big the huge
story within 10 weeks which is
unbelievable
you know we shot our little donkey
for
I don't know how many seven or eight
weeks
and
so it's it's an achievement it's it's
it's an unbelievable thing
and I also ask him
about the
editing time
and I wasn't surprised by the answer
that it took over six months
to edit this huge story
um I guess there was a lot of material
which
the director had to live on the
editing room floor
and I know how painful process it is
because I went through such experience a
couple of times in my
filmmaking career
but
what's the most important is the fact
that this film was executed with such a
precision and and such a
um
attention to every detail every little
part
was acted in the
in the in the best possible way
and the main part
it's a really a huge Oscar contender in
my opinion it's
it's very very well played part which
normally actors don't like to play
because it's
you know it has a
quite many so-called empty moments you
know in a private life when
he goes from one room to the other when
he talks to his wife and daughter
and Son those are not
incredibly exciting moments and the
actors
prefer the parts which with the
with the emotions which are up on the
sleeve you know not not so much
withdrawn and this actor really played
it
sensationally well
what else I should say
thank you very much thank you
Santiago
tell us something about Edward's film
All Quiet on the Western Front
yeah I I I was uh
it was an amazing experience to watch
the film and discover the film for the
first time I knew uh very little about
the novel now I know because we have
been sharing so many panels all together
so I know kind of uh some of the secrets
of Edwards we like Secrets
he will probably tell it better than me
but but it was a it was a very uh
it was a very impressive experience to
watch a film I mean not not only because
of the all the technical achievements
that the film has which is beautifully
shot with an amazing photography uh the
music is so original and so and it
brings uh so much tension the makeup
everything in the family is so so good
which is uh which is something that me
as a filmmaker who I like the craft of
the film like it it's uh it's something
that I that I that I can admire and I
can
but but also it's uh I mean I I do um
political films and I'm very interested
in in politics so uh
to watch this story was was the kind of
story that what I what I feel uh
compelled and and interesting I think
it's uh such an such an important film
in this uh in this period of the world
uh where we
well as suffering so much tragedies
so uh I I think that that it's a
relevant and a film about uh
besides being a telling the story of uh
which year was it the story it's uh 19
1918 it finishes okay 16 to 18. okay and
um no and also I mean that's one
sequence what I thought it was brilliant
um and it's in the beginning uh how how
he he follows the battlefield to the to
the uh to the well and then the clothes
of this this soldier that dies and then
goes to to the new soldiers
everything's there uh the cruelty of of
the politics uh the cruelty of of the
world the insane of of uh of the
violence that uh and the knife nurse or
Ingenuity of the people who go who
accept that uh us uh so like this sort
of nationalistic
fascist or whatever Ingenuity that some
people have and so that's why they
Embrace those causes then I mean I I was
really interested I was really from for
me was
yeah I I love the the character is
amazing and he drives the film uh uh
amazingly and uh and also I love the
this uh I don't know I need some I
cannot contrast maybe yeah the contrast
between the politicians and the and the
war because then then there you see uh
like uh
I don't know if the real tragedy on the
war on that uh
on that tension which which I thought it
was a brilliant shown in the film so
thank you for this film Edward thank you
thank you and finally Lucas please tell
us about the quiet girl
cried girl
um well I have to say that the last stop
I made before coming here was the Dublin
Film Festival
and so when I arrived in Ireland and I
drove there and all these posters of the
quiet girl surrounded me I was a little
bit scared to present close in front of
an audience full of Irish people I was I
was like oh my God are they gonna be
receptive to us
they were very warm but what was very
beautiful to feel is this sort of
proudness that there was for this film
for this Irish Jewel that you made with
your team I could feel that you moved
just by feeling the atmosphere in this
audience that you moved so many Irish
people and so many people outside of
Ireland of course but that proudness
that I felt really marked me
um yeah I think it's something
extraordinary and
when I think of your film
I immediately think of that image of the
grass
hearing that name and then slowly
discovering that there's this young girl
hiding there
who wants to disappear
who wants so much not to be found not to
be seen
and I thought it was such a beautiful
extraordinary opening of this film
I of course feel incredibly connected to
your peace
for many reasons of course we both have
child actors but also I think in many
ways our films are about healing
I think you have this young character
who has experienced tragedy early in
life
and you have this couple of parents who
have experienced it later
and those two meeting each other
and through their connectedness finding
a way out of the bruising
I thought was extraordinary
really
it gave me goosebumps when I was
watching your film
throughout I thought there was a
confidence to your filming your
cinematographer who I got a chance to
meet did extraordinary work but
everything in your film felt so tender
and at the same time confronted
something so dark
um
I think your film is about human nature
but it's also about how reconnecting to
Nature can help us find ourselves
um
I'm in awe of what you did with that
film
and I will never forget that last moment
when she's running towards him and that
last Embrace that just went through my
whole body and my soul and my heart and
will stay there forever
so thank you
[Applause]
so
the reason for doing this is exactly
what happened
is that the love isn't just in the room
and in the emotion but it becomes verbal
and articulate
we are a group of filmmakers we are a
group and we love each other's work and
that is so important that that's why we
are here and that's why all of you guys
are here
this particular particular degree
dedicated to films not in English
language
we would like to ask all of you how does
culture tie to a language and what does
it do to facilitate the understanding of
the complexity of the world because
we'll we are in a world right now where
everything is so accessible in English
everything is so accessible in yeah
particularly in English and so to make
movies in other languages you
immediately you immediately mirror a
different culture
what does that mean to each of you
um who do you want to start right
um well let's start on this end I mean
I'm looking at you Colin because you
know you you are the first time guy and
you know representing the Irish language
for the first time at the Oscars is huge
accomplishment
but let's start with Edward
I was hoping you would start with calm
but um
um
I mean for me language was
in this case very important there's
obviously it's a famous novel a German
novel
uh written in that language by a German
writer who then eventually came to Los
Angeles he fled Germany during the war
during the second world war and found
Refuge here and
um and there was obviously a movie made
in America
in English
and so for me the only reason to make
this film was to make it in German uh if
it had been in English I would have said
like why there is one you know and and a
very good one
um but it's not I mean language is
almost a superficial
um
attribute in this case because it's sort
of you can translate a script and make
it in German or in English or in Irish
or Spanish
um
it's more about the feeling that that
language brings in the soul of the
culture uh and the culture is very or
the the history let's say if if we make
it specific for this movie the history
of a German filmmaker what he's
inherited or what she's inherited in my
case uh um is that is very different
from an American filmmaker who would
make a war film
uh and in America you can have a story
of Heroes you can have a story of people
who liberate who fulfill a mission are
successful and uh come home and are sort
of celebrated and honored uh and they've
come home with a sense of Pride because
of your history you know America was
roped into the second world in both
world wars liberated Europe and Fascism
and that leaves a very different sort of
Trace in the DNA of the fit of the
generations to come and the filmmakers
and that thus leaves a very different
film and I thought in Germany if we make
a film about the war and about this
novel you cannot have a hero uh you
cannot have
um someone who survives in the end you
um uh someone who you know fulfills a
mission or you know kind of have the
sense of Pride and and and any death in
that movie must be a horrible life lost
you know and cannot be sort of let's say
an obstacle that you put aside in order
to get to your goal and so I thought
that would be just an interesting
addition in terms of the dialogue
between movies between an American film
a lot more between a German film about a
war uh and any other country so
um for me that language was basically
the core of the movie
well it is the core of movies it is so
interesting because
because exactly it can't be the same
movie it is Windows into the entire
world
column you want to pick it up I mean you
don't even necessarily have to speak
about your own film in this context all
yours yours is a landmark clearly for
for Irish Cinema but um yeah just talk
about what it what it's meant and how
your thoughts on this sure yeah um I
suppose it's important to
to state that like our film isn't is an
adaptation actually of an English
language text so it's based on a a long
short story called Foster written by
Claire Keegan
um
but the decision to to to move that
story into an Irish language space
to me always felt
kind of appropriate because Foster
itself is
is such a beautiful rendering of of us
as a people in terms of our emotional
and psychological makeup I feel and you
know in Ireland the the form of English
that we speak is actually carries all of
these sort of ghosts in a sense of the
Irish language so there's even a term
for the English that we speak in Ireland
which is hybrino English because Ireland
used to be was known as Hibernia by the
Romans so that was the Latin term for it
and hiberno English is a is a
description of a form of English that
that carries all of these inflections
and
um and memories in a sense of of this
other language this entirely different
language the most ancient language in
Europe
um
so for me it always felt quite
appropriate that a story that's so much
about us as a people
that I should tell that story in our own
language you know
um
and you know when I read faster and I
read the dialogue and faster I can see
as an Irish speaker I can see the Irish
language in the words that these people
are saying to one another so even Irish
people themselves are unbeknownst to
themselves or giving expression to this
ancient mode of expression that we that
we had
um
and it was also you know I'm I'm an
Irish speaker and I was I was raised
bilingually so my my born in Dublin and
raised in Dublin
um my mum spoke English in her house and
my dad always spoke ours my dad's never
spoken English to me so the Irish
language has always been a huge part of
my life
um
although I had a sort of a tortured
relationship with it when I was younger
because
you know we were kind of like a just
different family in our housing estate
and at that age you know you want to fit
in you don't want to be the
the weird family that are you know the
people kind of look at or whatever and
yet my dad would insist on you know
coming out onto the street and like
crawling down the street in Irish and is
you know shouting down like come on in
for dinner or whatever in Irish and uh
other kids would be kind of looking at
you kind of going because your dad in
the ira or
so there was all kind of which you
wasn't um
um but my dad just was a linguist really
had a deep love of languages and and
believed in the preservation of the
language
um and I guess that that's something
that I came to realize that
you know even though I spent most of my
adolescence speaking English back to him
um I did come to realize that it was a
beautiful gift to be given a second
language and to be given our own
language
um
and I guess he knew that all Sons
eventually become their fathers because
uh you know myself and my wife cleoni
crudi who's the producer of the film
with two young boys and I can't speak
English to them
so um
but yeah it was I guess you know there's
a there's a part of me that that kind of
has been thinking about like the silence
in our film
and having a way
in a rather neat way it's you know it
almost speaks to the way in which our
own language was silenced for so long
um
and that our language is a little bit
like the quiet girl in our film
that's been
downtrodden and
forgotten in some ways
but that my My Hope Is and this is the
hope that I have in my own children and
in a way in in the girl in our film
that you know she she is given a chance
in a sense and she's seen for the first
time and she's
she's given space
and they're all things that that our
language needs and I'm hoping that in
some way that our language has caught
those in our film
that our language will sort of find its
voice again
um
and I looked at my own children
ask the future in that regard
I I wanted to follow on that they have a
comment on absolutely yeah I was going
to point to you especially about The
Silence part I understand the complex of
the your language situation especially
the greatest book ever written
was written in Dublin
but not in English but in a very special
language
which
also must have a huge effect on your
attitudes to languages and on the other
note I must say I had
much easier situation because all the
donkeys around the world speak exactly
the same language
[Applause]
Lucas language is much more in Conflict
perhaps or maybe not in in Belgium I
mean the Flemish language and French I
mean their their distinct cultures
wrapped up in each of those maybe speak
a little bit about how you address that
in close or just your thoughts in
General on that yeah I was thinking
about the question and then also
thoughts that maybe for me
of course this is It's specific it's in
French and Dutch but I think in in in
this film it's so much about the
language of the body
or the language of the heart which is as
universal as the one of the donkeys I
think I think it transcends borders in a
way
I think we all go through life and and
we grow up and we feel these things that
connect us whether we live in America or
in Belgium
or in India
and and I think that is
what we've tried with with this film is
to speak about that Universal experience
of growing up
um I think when we write we very much
write choreographies
um I think in the beginning our scripts
feel a little bit like dance
performances more than they feel like
movies
it's actually my co-writer who said
who's in the theater right now raise
your hand Angelo
yeah who um
[Applause]
who who reminds me that people actually
speak sometimes and so then I then we
add dialogue and then we add language
but in the beginning there's really not
much and um
and I like that I I like to treat teams
through their physicality
and uh
and to start really by by putting the
Body Central
and then next to that the languages of
course in Belgium we speak three
languages and we have decided to really
let French and Flemish coexist
um our sides of the country industry are
quite divided and it's always been my
sort of ambition to work with the two
sides and to really unite them in this
film I think for a young generation
they are confronted with the fact that
these languages coexist in such an
organic way and I kind of want these
films to also be an example of that
[Applause]
um language
um
it's something uh probably obvious but I
that I truly believe that cinemites it's
the language not not the language itself
it's a universal language I mean I I
grew I
I've been uh watching films all my life
and I probably was watching many more
films from other places of the world and
from from Argentina when I started to
watch Cinema because of this week
tradition of Hollywood and it's what uh
well it's everywhere so I was used to
read subtitles so that opened me the
possibility to to to get to through
Cinema to cinema all over the world so I
well
I mean I that's that's one of the things
that uh that I that I like under and
that and I and I think they're important
what what uh Edward said about uh the
importance of doing that film in German
it's it's a thing that uh
for me it's like unimaginable these days
like to go and tell a story in uh in
another language the language defines
the the place probably so it's uh well
I'm I'm an engineer and I do a films in
Argentina uh so it's uh
it's not only a
the language uh it's also the the
expressions and the precisions of the
words and in my uh specific uh case of
on the specific case of my film it was a
film about lawyers so lawyers choose
their words so it was uh it was very
important for me on the way on way way
we we well we built the script and then
we and then we shoot it but also in the
way that we recreate uh the scenes on
the on the trial that we
we used uh the exact same words that
were used in the in the in the public
Parts like uh totally verbatim
so um I don't know what else to say
let's go on
well I I think I think what we I think
trying to to address is none of those
movies could have been made in English
they are very specific not just because
of the language but because of the sense
of culture because of the the story is
centered around something undefined
which is
articulated by language
and
like
I have for example have had some of a
couple of my movies remade in English
and it has been quite interesting
because it's not even a question about
whether they're good or bad there is an
essential
element which is just remarkably
different and and doesn't necessarily
work in a different language
and that's why which is why it is very
interesting to hear what your thoughts
are on this particular subject
um
do we
we still have a little time and in that
time this is in a way
um
uh it's not it's not an ending but
perhaps u5 will not be on stage in this
manner again
um and I we just wanted to provide an
opportunity for you just to share a
little bit about what it's been like to
be in the world with your films in some
cases together in some cases alone with
your teams anything from this past year
cycle for some of you
um that stands out to you any memories
any particular moment
and this
this also like if any of the audience
had a brief question we would love to
have just a second for it
um who starts anybody who wants yeah and
who starts
call
um
I mean there's there have been so many
it's just been the most incredible year
um and the fact that I've
shared every step of the way with with
my wife who's the producer has just been
incredible um
but I guess you know
the day that we found out we were going
to be here was incredible like we got we
kind of took a gamble we got like a
whole load of people together in a
cinema kind of like this and we watched
the announcement of the nominees
um
and I'll always remember
the word or the two letters EO because
they were the fourth film that was
called ice and then it was followed by
the quiet girl and then Madness ensued
and
we had cameras there to capture it but
uh so the gamble kind of paid off but it
was that was just a beautiful sort of
moment in that we we got to share it all
together as as a crew and as a cast and
uh because we had filmed and you know
during covid we'd know rap party we'd
know we didn't have that sort of
social uh moment together where we got
to embrace one another and and celebrate
what we had what we had just done so
to do so in that in that moment with all
of those people was enormously special
for us and it's just something that
we'll never forget
great
yeah
[Applause]
from my experience of showing EO
the one which really uh
gives me
a personal hope
that
there were some deeper sense in making
this film
not only
like the usual work on the film
I made several of them and
only very few were really good
so um
and by the way the worst film which I
made ever
has also something to do with language
because I stupidly dare
to try to adapt
one
of Polish books
of the author you may not be familiar
with his name
his name is gombrovich
and he had written a book called
ferdurge
which doesn't mean anything it's it's a
nonsense word
and
but the quality of the book
is that he used the the Polish language
in a completely different
way
than it was used by the classic polish
literature
he was making fun of the language
he was making
criticism of the of the Polish
characters which were
speaking in a
specific way
it was a very subtle caricature of the
Polish Society
customs
and language
and I tried to make this film
but I didn't make it in Polish I decided
to make it in English
which was the stupidest thing
especially that I had the international
crew
and cast International caste
um
I had
quite well known American actor
a couple of British actors some French
actresses
they all spoke English in a different
way with the different accents so
it was it was a total disaster
the worst film I ever made and I stopped
making films after that
and I stopped because I thought I have
to rethink I have to find myself
in the different
different state of mind to not repeat
such a
an unreasonable decision
but the point is
that
we have to be very careful with language
and choosing the language not ever
repeat my mistake
that's one thing which I wanted to tell
and then the other thing is that
perhaps because of that experience I try
to
avoid as much as possible of the
dialogue
I managed to have to made one film after
after death
that bad one
where the main hero
didn't say a single word
that film was called essential killing
the main actor was Vincent Gallo
and he never opened his mouth to say a
word
and
the problem with the dialogue generally
is either is bad then it's obviously bad
or it's too good
which is also bad
because you feel
the the written words you know the it it
brings you closer to the theater
so the less dialogue is better for
for the firms Eva tells me that I should
finish because I'm
okay one more thing you know what is my
favorite line of of your film
I had the liquids dinner
[Laughter]
that that is incredibly special we um
we're getting close we're they're gonna
play us off but um it is the Oscars but
let's let's give everyone that's good
comments okay brief I was I was gonna
say I'm Gonna Cancel all the English
language projects that I felt like doing
now thank you for the advice
um
uh well the the most the most beautiful
thing for me has been filming this this
piece with two young boys
and then seeing them grow up into two
young men who have mustaches now and who
talk about all these things they're
actually here with us in the theater can
you stand up boys
[Applause]
Gustav and where's Eden
can we just really briefly San Diego and
yeah
no there's so many things that I could
mention about the whole process on being
showing this film but I think one of the
more interesting things that that this
experience gives you is like to be in uh
and festivals in general or panels to be
able to share time to other film with
other filmmakers and to listen to them
the ideas advices to share experiences I
think that's one of the best things of
of being uh on this uh
having the lack of going through these
experiences
[Applause]
the nicest thing I think about this
journey was we had a crew from the Czech
Republic from Germany uh actors from
France Austria Germany and we always
came together every few weeks in London
or Paris or in New York or L.A and met
each other and was always such a nice
meeting and we became such good friends
the movie really brought us together it
was always like a wonderful party
basically when we met and we stayed up
to long hours and now we're all here and
that's an incredible experience and
you're still staying up to long hours
the hours haven't ended these are your
2023 Oscar nominees best International
feature
thank you very much oh now we're doing a
class photo but everyone has to leave
thank you all thank you all so much for
being here
thank you
[Applause]